I've already decided see my like if you
look up urban dictionary wants a Raylan
mother of unicorn
[Music]
hey happy Friday welcome back to
certified country I'm Sophie Scholl AC
and today we're a Lynne is joining me
I'm so excited you guys because today
she is helping me achieve peak unicorn
vibes all right we're here with Aubrey
who is Raylan's resident glam guru and
she's gonna be giving me the life's of
festival treatment I'm so excited
alright so first I'm gonna go ahead and
add a pop of color to her eyes it's pink
and then it's kind of got like a blue
replay it's crazy right it'll turn turn
different colors that's the one I've
been wearing everyday like not even
kidding this one is you know with like a
basic t-shirt it's so pretty
I love it and that's another like the
theme here right like everything
shimmers everything kind of changes
color right all their lip shades they
turn different colors and it's crazy cuz
this this one looks like it's yellow but
then it turns pink
that's so just so I'm gonna put mermaid
tears on you so this one is green in the
tube which is like a little intimidating
that it's gorgeous it's nice though cuz
they look a little different on every
skin tone and they work with your body
chemistry
every lipstick in the collection has a
as a coordinating topper which is
awesome mm-hmm
it's so pretty just pumps up the shine a
little bit darker on her skin too he's
so pretty there is a highlighter in the
in the eyeshadow palette but they also
launched a rainbow highlighter which is
so cool I'm obsessed at coordinate so
like so you can do it like a rainbow
stripe on your cheek or you can mix them
all together okay I'm gonna do on you
and I think that's what Raylan has on -
it's so light that you could wear it
every day and it not look cloudy you
know what I mean like it looks yeah I'm
so curious it's awesome cuz it's subtle
it's not like you know crazy hmm
you just have to swipe yeah we did the
photos for it we had to like do it like
four times to be able to show you can
see it okay so we've got the rainbow in
the side yes blend it on the side like
so
and then to finish off we've got the
setting spray the festival refresh this
is awesome you shake it up and your
little ball in there okay and it is
to reset and just refresh your makeup
and keep it on longer and give you that
dewy unicorn glow is also good is smell
good oh my gosh you look like a unicorn
Oh fabulous okay I want to do this
beauty rapid-fire round with you when do
you feel most beautiful probably right
after a shower and like I clean my face
and if I don't some lotion just like I
feel like it's super natural and glowy
and pretty how long is your morning
beauty routine I can get ready in like
20 minutes
pretty best what is one product that you
cannot leave home without lip gloss
what is your best-kept beauty secret I
do a face mask once a week okay that's a
really a beauty secret but that's one
thing that I always do religiously what
is one beauty trend that you really just
can't get behind some people were
getting eyebrow extensions and I don't
so I think it was like starting to try
be it like it was a like I want to be a
trend but it's not gonna happen kind of
train yeah I said okay we just need to
stop like this is not gonna stop the new
Song Festival out a new like pop EDM
side of you and I love that you also
just signed to tree vibes yeah that's
MGL guys Congrats on that thank you
those guys are special humans they the
way that they cater talent is super
awesome and they're just such a great
place to be able to create music how's
it been writing with those guys oh my
gosh it's so much fun we dissenter
writing retreats earlier this year is
that were you a tree house yeah yeah
I've been so much fun oh my gosh you
wrote some killer song yeah oh my god
yeah they'll be out this year I feel
like every time I see you you always
have a ton of new songs I love it
writing is my therapy it's the way that
I've you know get things out of my head
feelings you know just like if I'm if
I'm upset about something I have to
write about does writing so much though
make you itch to release the next album
like always
I mean I've written at least in the last
year and a half at least
I would say 20 to 30 songs yeah yeah
that's pretty good
so are you getting antsy - yeah all the
time
I work over coming up with what we're
gonna release next do you have a
timeline on that or an idea now I'm you
soon soon okay super vague I like it
soon I mean you know like I'm not
getting in trouble today
I'm not get in trouble today no no no
not today
can you give us any sort of teaser on
what's inspiring you I'm just really
thankful for all the amazing people have
around me and a lot of the strong women
that I have around me in um a lot of my
favorite women have inspired a lot of
the music that I'm writing right now I
saw your buddy Blake the other day at
the voice are you guys cooking up
anything fun these days oh my gosh I
hope soon he's just a such a delight
he's such an incredible person and just
I honestly don't know where I'd be
without his guidance and him hitting a
drive button for me 17 you really did
change my life yeah I love that thank
you so much for being here I always love
having you here been my unicorn sister
thank y'all so much for watching be sure
to come see us again next Friday we'll
be right here on YouTube
you